hey guys Ryan right over here Jerry over
here we're gonna be checking out this
video that people have been asking me to
judge for like two months now called
Batman ace chemicals part three that is
an especially later yeah I'm usually
right on it when it comes to turnarounds
these days but but I'm doing catch-up
this week so I just showed Jerry part 1
& 2 and he was like jizan all over the
place it was awesome
Jerry's jizz that's the new channel it's
like the name of a terrible ice cream
parlor
oh here we go oh he's doing it
not easy
hi that's what both already dead you
know about the bomb is building right
where is he I heard him saying he was an
essential mixing chamber no he's getting
ready to release his toxic gas gets out
there it's gonna be chaos I won't let
that happen
I'm getting you out of here get to the
elevator
really something
I'm going to fill the arkham knight what
happens when he messes with my city
thump gameplay by the way is it really
or I'm pretty sure I'm [ __ ] with you
okay just because people will will check
you on that one
well the [ __ ] going on
is like Silent Hill madmen
like this is
the hellish
he has all the right guns that's cool
sweet snap diggity that was a good time
so those aren't people those are not
people in there apparently
I once says well be those are drones and
he's just shooting them with guns but
they're drones see that's like having
your cake and eating it too though
because it's like they look just like he
might as well be killing people like it
might as well yeah that was it's not
badass like it's a badass it's a badass
clip ask that Oh nightmare mission that
nightmare mission bitless was freaking
yeah that's like dark I remember playing
in the previous game anything with
scarecrow like it is actually pretty
scary to be a part of when you're
playing it it feels like you're in the
underbelly of Satan's [ __ ] at that
point yeah why should that click like
that wasn't like a cool that man that
was like a hellish looking night yeah it
was like straight out of like Resident
Evil Silent Hill kind of [ __ ] it felt
didn't look no it didn't look fun but I
think makes me want to play the game and
see what it is it's cool cuz you know
like anything with scarecrow dealing
like Batman's nightmares is always kind
of fun to watch because you know Batman
has a lot of trauma apparently who would
have thought what I thought was a little
cheesy was cool when Batman was like
taking out all those guys one by one a
part of my brain was going why are they
attacking him one by wonderers he just
going so fast he's taking them out one
by one
cuz he's so fast he's too good for
punitive brains this worker guy he's
totally lost all hope even though he
just saw this one guy in a bat suit just
[ __ ] up everyone around him and he's
like it's too late man too late bro
ain't gonna happen
[ __ ] ain't working man I'm the only
gonna blow dude yeah I just like this
guy it's fresh out of a frat party yeah
bruh give it up brah dude you look like
a [ __ ] bat right now okay now here's
where B sounds stupid yeah you ready to
sound stupid with me jerk I'm gonna
sound stupid doing half this video I
thought Arkham Knight was referring to
bat yeah I did too but maybe that's the
twist baby it's like
maybe Batman is both he is the good guy
and the bad guy in this be a weird
Elseworlds comedy yeah it would be like
high tension but 10 times more confusing
as to how Batman got to all these
locations what these ace chemicals
videos are really showing me is that
Batman has upgraded his mindset into gun
technology significantly more even in
his scarecrow nightmare where he's
running through the pits of hell he's
like if I just get to my Batmobile with
guns I can solve this problem Batman's a
dark character I've always associated
madmen more like brooding dark yeah and
in these videos he just looks angry and
pissed up like like he just wants to
[ __ ] [ __ ] up but still for justice yeah
yeah it does look like a dog like I
wouldn't want to hang out with this
Batman know this Batman looks skin I
want a Batman like this in a movie like
the Batman part you know yeah I'd like a
more charming Bruce Wayne you know
something like Christian gray from Fifty
Shades is great it would make sense if
you had if you had a Batman who's like a
sex addict and it makes it would make
sense he already likes dressing up in
leather when he fights crime so yeah
Batman's equipped with guns now he's
darker he's badder he's yeah that's her
yeah and he he's huge like [ __ ] huge
yeah he looks like he's like six six and
he weighs it like 300 pounds of pure
muscle
I feel like they'd be able to know it's
Batman because of how buff he is yeah
they would suspect something about Bruce
Wayne like yeah what why does he work
for this government is made shockingly
similar technology yeah I'd like to play
this I just have to wait like the first
four games
oh they're fun I play most of them I
feel like I'm gonna have to take a break
every hour though just prevent myself
from getting to like angry oh yeah no
pretend just feel like playing these
games like the anger rubs off of you
because like the punches and everything
like everything is so hard and I feel
like I'd have to take a break for a
second and remember the
you know like well that's why you have a
hatred in the other room so you could
play hatred to get out your anger on
society I forgot about hatred oh I'll
never forget about hatred yeah if they
need help promoting that game I'm your
guy
hey guys thanks for telling us that
video is out if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects Jerry does movie reviews often
different from the ones I review huh
collaborative on the channel are we mult
diverse I've almost said multiverse the
multiverse or the multiverse the one
Jerry have sub show reasons to Jerry
where he does movie reviews in his car
pisses people off cuz he's talking in
his car which is it is illegal in some
ways yeah but I mean if that's what
makes this channel work I'm just worried
you rode will I do it it's probably for
the worst and shoutouts what continues
to go to facebook.com slash the real
reject shoutouts where you can earn
yourself a shot up I sense something
interesting like Jerry's jizz is the
best jizz on the planet don't say that
you don't know J jizz don't talk about
memes is eg a yo what's up with jizz EJ
over there huh that sounds like juicy j
EO Juicy J is cool that's coming up that
is not gonna be my rapping name if I
remember an MC that is not gonna be my
mom's you see just that be a great name
you can then you can have it please I
love to take juicy jerseys well mine
will be spelled je w sy Suzie Suzie
cheated it'll be very curly